[Music]
on this Wednesday night beating the heat
more record-breaking temperatures it's
going to get a lot worse raising fears
for the vulnerable and Canadian Farmers
taking a bite out of the grocery bill
the government rolls out a rebate but
will it satisfy Shoppers a 48 year old
Cold Case cracked how new technology
identified an American woman murdered in
Ontario
National with Donna Friesen reporting
tonight Jeff Semple good evening and
thank you for joining us this summer is
off to a sweltering start with tens of
millions in North America under heat
warnings tonight and temperature records
are falling fast 2016 and 2020 were the
hottest years on record according to
NASA but this year average temperatures
are trending even higher last month was
the warmest June ever recorded and
Monday and Tuesday of this week also set
new records for the hottest days ever
with yesterday's average global
temperature climbing to 17.18 degrees
experts expect more record-breaking heat
in the weeks ahead and there's growing
concern for the vulnerable those without
the means to escape the scorching
temperatures Eric Sorensen has our top
story tonight
they're outside they're basically just
surviving
Jacinda Hudson is Distributing water
checking up on the homeless in downtown
Toronto they live in tents and are among
the most vulnerable Canadians facing a
future with increasing heat every summer
they're doing the best that they can
with what they have but
I mean that's why we're here we're
trying to assist trying to help out just
give some water and at least alleviate a
little bit of stress from them it's not
inner city it's every city the elderly
living alone on low incomes are also at
risk and those with pre-existing health
conditions when the heat events hit we
have to map out where are these people
in society where are they living and we
have to make sure that we have people
checking on them on on a regular basis
it's not just the heat it's the humidity
the more humid it is the more difficult
it is and the slower it is for us to be
able to transfer heat out of our body
Ira Jacobs says the risk climbs when the
humidex reaches 40 if people can't cool
off we can in fact do damage to cells
and key organs in our body because of
the temperature that actually uh occurs
inside of our body social service
agencies says this is especially true
for the unhoused who often have poor
health and habits on top of life on the
street you turn up some of the
vulnerabilities that are inherent in
heat and it's going to increase the it
will reduce their resiliency to bounce
back for many of the traumas that they
face on a daily basis the World Health
Organization reports tens of millions
more people around the world are exposed
to heat waves than a generation ago
under the 2021 heat Dome over British
Columbia around 600 people died from
extreme heat last week BC began
accepting applications for 8 000 free
air conditioning units for low-income
medically vulnerable people and Ottawa
announced it's working with provinces on
a one and a half billion dollar plan for
climate adaptation that communities will
need we must also make our communities
more resilient to the impacts of climate
change as challenging as extreme heat
may be at this moment it's going to get
a lot worse period across Canada climate
adaptation policies will take years to
roll out but the needs of the vulnerable
are immediate the heat is everywhere and
increasing and so is the population most
at risk Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto those high temperatures come
bind with a lack of rain are causing
droughts for Canadian farmers in Alberta
some key growing regions have received
less than 50 millimeters of moisture
since the beginning of May several
communities have declared agricultural
disasters that happens when 50 to 90
percent of a municipality is
experiencing extreme loss of crops
Foothills County south of Calgary was
the latest to reach that Grim threshold
declaring a disaster last week it joins
three other municipalities in Alberta's
Southern farming Community with others
expected to follow in the coming weeks
as Heather York's West explains the
conditions are now forcing some Farmers
to reassess their futures
Ryan Cook is a cattle rancher nothing is
more important than his herd
[Music]
is central Alberta Farm has spent years
perfecting its breeding program it's why
this year is so heartbreakingly hard I
think we'll have to sell some not sure
yet the genetics you bring in and
produce is what makes your coward better
and and uh
it takes a lifetime to build that up so
it's basically you're throwing away a
lifetime if you have to sell them
drought conditions in settler County
mean this Farm likely won't have enough
feed to get their cattle through the
winter across Alberta cook is far from
alone
before July to have that already headed
out like that like it's not growing
anymore now
South and central Alberta four Counties
have declared an agricultural disaster
for some Farms the lack of rain and high
temperatures have resulted in 90 percent
crop loss the Alberta Government says
it's monitoring the situation closely as
soil moisture levels in Central and
Southern Alberta hit 50-year lows this
year had to truck all of our cattle up
North for pasture because there was none
down here it could turn into the top
five worst crops we've ever had for sure
and like I said we've been this will be
six out of seven years that we've had to
dip into crop insurance we spent 600
thousand dollars on crop insurance
premiums this year and while one year of
drought is hard enough many areas have
been dealing with several seasons with
very little rain here in stetler County
a disaster has been declared in three of
the last six years prompting concerns
over what's to come it's hard
to continue on
when the resources aren't there to carry
you
an industry as iconic to Alberta as oil
struggling through season after season
without enough rain
Heather urich's West Global News stetler
County Alberta
the government's grocery rebate is
rolling out today to help low-income
Canadians with the rising cost of living
around 11 million Canadians are
receiving the one-time payment arriving
by check or direct deposit alongside
July's GST tax credit those funds were
promised in the federal budget with a
price tag of 2.5 billion dollars Korea
isri reports on whether the rebate will
offer any relief
watermelon pineapple to
um ground beef this is what fifty
dollars gets you at the grocery store my
money only goes to my food and my rent
and there's nothing left for my tuition
this University student will have a bit
more wiggle room a few hundred dollars
is coming her way she's one of millions
of Canadians receiving a one-time
payment the government has branded as a
grocery rebate families with children
are getting between 387 and 628 dollars
single Canadians are receiving 234
dollars while seniors are getting 225
dollars I'll take whatever they they
give
okay it's it it's very expensive to uh
today's world
money doesn't have to go towards buying
groceries it can be spent on anything
but for this mother the rebate barely
covers her monthly bill for formula and
diapers every week and a half at least
I'm spending about 140 120 and that's
not touching groceries
the average family is spending roughly a
thousand dollars more this year than
last on food for the people who need it
the most it's gonna make a difference
is it going to cover everything no
Ottawa insists it needs to strike a
balance to avoid fueling inflation those
untargeted measures can be kind of
worrisome the good news is that the GST
credit is actually very well targeted
some Canadians believe the rebate is the
wrong approach they want the government
to fight price gouging at the grocery
store instead because there are so few
major chains it is reducing competition
which doesn't provide much incentive for
people to you know keep their prices
very low only Canadians who have filed
their taxes will qualify for the
so-called grocery rebate
Ottawa plans to introduce automatic
filing so that vulnerable Canadians
don't miss out on their benefits but
Advocates insist the best way for the
government to reduce poverty is by
investing in housing
Taria esri Global News Ottawa
turning to breaking news now Ottawa has
just struck a deal with stellantis and
LG Energy Solutions that means the
construction of their electric vehicle
battery plant in Windsor Ontario is back
on track the two companies made the
announcement after reaching a financing
deal with the federal government
construction stalled earlier this year
after the companies demanded more
Government funding to match what the U.S
would offer under its new inflation
reduction Act
police in Quebec say two bodies have
been found near the site of Saturday's
landslide that hit the provinces sagane
laksenjon region a state of emergency
was declared after the local River
swelled to four times its size from
torrential rains dozens were forced to
evacuate and two people were reported
missing a man and woman in their 40s
Quebec's coroner's office has so far
identified one of the bodies as
48-year-old Pascal aeon from the Quebec
City region
Ontario Police have cracked one of
Canada's oldest cold cases dating back
almost half a century the victim was
known only as the nation River lady
after her body was found floating in the
nation River East of Ottawa back in
1975. she has now finally been
identified as Jewel Parchman Langford
investigators say the Breakthrough was
thanks to advances in DNA testing
technology like the kind used to
determine someone's ancestry
the DNA sample was linked with others
through a genealogy and family tree
analysis and raised a a good potential
that the missing per the unidentified
remains were Ms Langford
in 2020 a new DNA profile was created
and within a few weeks Langford was
identified as the likely candidate
investigators believe this is the first
case in Canada where human remains have
been identified using forensic genealogy
Langford was first reported missing
after arriving in Montreal from
Tennessee and police have now charged 81
year old Florida man Rodney Nichols with
her murder
on the eve of the 10th anniversary of
one of Canada's worst rail disasters in
Lac Meg antique people in the community
are calling for more action to avoid
another tragedy
tomorrow marks a decade since 47 people
were killed after a runaway train
carrying crude oil derailed on the Main
Street of the small town
lacmaig antique has never been the same
and as Dan Specter reports the community
says there's been little progress to
improve rail safety
it's one of those towns where everyone
knows everyone which is a major reason
the hellish Knight that marked this
place a decade ago has been so hard to
forget we lost our heart you know
July 6 2013 just after one o'clock in
the morning a runaway train carrying 72
tanker Cars full of crude oil derailed
and exploded in the Town Center killing
47 people and destroying dozens of
buildings the Train's brakes failed
while it was parked up the hill in the
neighboring town of nalt it picked up
speed as it barreled down the slope
before derailing at the curve
Padre there were no lights no brakes
zilfuel says the train rushed silently
by him that night without a sound
minutes before he'd left The Downtown
Bar where many of the victims lived
their final moments ten years later
there's still a curve in the middle of
town
the mayor says today's trains are longer
than ever creating constant concern she
says plans are moving forward to create
a rail bypass around the town though
even that has sparked controversy among
the 42 landowners affected
is part of a Citizens group that has
been lobbying for better rail safety
ever since the disaster they watched the
tracks closely and this week they posted
a video of tracks moving up and down at
this location he says over the years his
group has flagged many sections of track
they see as poorly maintained
I do think that uh profits
running before people's safety Canada
has tightened rail regulations added
inspectors but rail expert Ian Nash says
the rules aren't always enforced I'd say
they just haven't used them enough
and uh they can be a lot harsher he also
says companies are cutting corners on
safety in the name of profits though the
Canadian rail Association counters that
saying every railroader's singular
mission is to deliver the goods
Canadians need and use every day safely
a candlelight walk will take place just
after one o'clock Thursday morning
around the same time the catastrophe
began to unfold 10 years ago tomorrow
people will lay flowers along the tracks
downtown and at noon the church bell
will toll 47 times one for each of the
Dead Jeff Dan Specter in lach meganti
Quebec tonight thanks Dan
taking on the tech Giants
coming up the Federal government's
message from meta
in a first of its kind case in Canada
the RCMP have charged an Ottawa man with
both terrorism and hate offenses
26-year-old Patrick Gordon McDonald is
charged with three counts of
terrorism-related activities including
the willful promotion of hatred it's
alleged he helped produce propaganda
material for a hate group these are
screenshots of videos from that Neo-Nazi
Group which is listed as a terrorist
organization in Canada a second unnamed
person from Kinsey Falls Quebec was also
arrested
a new development tonight in the federal
government's dispute with American Tech
Giants over its online news act the
Heritage Minister says the government is
suspending advertising on Facebook and
Instagram the move follows meta's
decision to block news content on its
platforms to avoid paying Publishers
Mackenzie gray reports on the potential
impact and the hopes for a deal once in
a while once in a while it's a rare show
of parliamentary Unity the Liberals NDP
and block appearing together to support
the online news act and a push back
against one of the tech Giants we are
announcing the government of Canada will
be suspending advertising on Facebook
and Instagram but the move will likely
have little impact the FED spent only 11
million dollars last year on Facebook
and Instagram ads A Drop in the Ocean to
the more than 4 billion in Revenue meta
makes in Canada alone and the ban only
extends to the government the Liberal
Party itself which has used social media
ads extensively during elections will
continue to work with Instagram and
Facebook our contradiction the Prime
Minister couldn't explain as for other
organizations like political parties and
others I'm sure there will be more
decisions taken in the coming days
Google and meta have both said they'll
block Canadian news from Canadian users
after parliament passed new legislation
forcing Tech Giants to cut deals with
media publishers for sharing and
directing users to online news content
the Heritage minister is still confident
a deal can be reached with Google but
the conservatives say the law is flawed
unfortunately because of this
government's illogical tactic and lack
of common sense it is Canadians who are
going to be be harmed the Parliamentary
budget officer estimated the new law
would cost meta and Google roughly 300
million dollars annually but the Silicon
Valley Giants likely view this as a
bigger fight with similar legislation to
the Canadian model being considered in
California the world's fifth biggest
economy the user experience for for the
average Facebook user popping up and
saying you can't share news on this
platform is a bad experience and I think
they know that they're just willing to
take on that risk uh in in hopes of
trying to stop similar legislation
globally the federal government wasn't
the only entity to cut advertising with
meta the province of Quebec and Quebec
Corps which owns multiple media
organizations also announced similar
bands Jeff
Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thanks Mack
still ahead Ukraine and Russia accuse
each other of planning to attack
Europe's largest nuclear plant
hundreds of Palestinians took part in a
funeral procession for those killed in
an Israeli raid
mourners marched through the Janine
refugee camp where 12 Palestinians were
killed in the two-day raid it was one of
the biggest Israeli military operations
in the West Bank in two decades one
Israeli was also killed Israel has now
withdrawn its troops but fighting
continues today Palestinian militants
fired Rockets from Gaza the Israeli
military says they were intercepted by
its air defense systems
Ukraine and Russia are accusing each
other of plotting to sabotage one of the
world's largest nuclear plants Ukraine
claims Russia has planted objects
resembling explosives on the roof of the
zaparizia nuclear power plant Russia
says that's nonsense U.N inspectors also
say they've seen no evidence of that the
plant has been the target of attacks on
and off for more than a year Russia
seized that facility in the first days
of its full-scale invasion of Ukraine
thank you
Scotland presented King Charles with the
country's crown jewels the ceremony in
Edinburgh was held to honor the new
Monarch's coronation the day of pop and
pageantry was also marked by protests
along Scotland's Royal Mile with some in
the crowd chanting not my king and that
is global national for this Wednesday
night I'm Jeff Semple tonight's year
Canada is Minto bridge in ottawa's Rock
Cliff Park thanks for watching hope to
see you back here again tomorrow have a
great night
[Music]
foreign